paul ronzheimer für uns in kiew der
diese rede auch mitverfolgt hat paul wie
hast du diesen auftritt putins jetzt
gerade in
das war eine klassische propaganda rede
von wladimir putin eine rede die sich
vor allem nach innen orientiert hat aber
mit klaren ansagen an die internationale
gemeinschaft er sagt dass die sogenannte
spezialoperation hier heißt es krieg in
russland darf man das nicht sagen aber
dass dieser krieg weiter gehen wird so
hat er klar gemacht er hat gesagt du
hast es schon ausgeführt man sei
gezwungen gewesen
diese sonder operationen durchzuführen
dann wiederholt er die lügen dass es
angeblich ein genozid und völkermorde
gegeben habe im osten der ukraine das
muss man noch mal ganz klar einordnen
das ist falsch dafür gibt es keinerlei
beweise dass das dort passiert ist und
er wirft dem westen vor diese
völkermorde sozusagen unterstützt zu
haben es ist erneut eine eskalation von
wladimir putin da ist mit keinem wort zu
erkennen dass er in irgendeiner form an
einem dialog an verhandlungen
irgendetwas interessiert ist ganz im
gegenteil denn er wirft neben der frage
wie es militärisch weiter geht dem
westen vor dass diese sanktionen am ende
nur ihnen schaden also er sagt das ist
rousseau phobie gegen uns und sanktionen
und er sagt aber diese düsteren
perspektiven
die man gemacht hätte am beginn des
krieges die hätten sich nicht erfüllt
und russland sei weiter stabil
gleichzeitig gibt er bei der frage der
inflationär corona die schuld behauptet
das sei die weltwirtschaft das habe gar
nichts mit der spezialoperation zu tun
und dann sagt er europäische politiker
haben den eigenen leuten schaden
zugefügt und er spricht davon dass die
sanktionen angeblich 400 milliarden
dollar verlust gemacht hätten also
zusammengefasst erster wladimir putin
will diesen krieg weiterführen zweitens
er tut so als seien die sanktionen egal
und drittens behauptet er mit russland
geht alles den erfolgreichen weg und
paula hat sich auch mächtig selbst auf
die schulter geklopft er hat zum
beispiel gesagt dass diese ganzen
sanktionen ihnen gar nicht treffen und
russland weiterhin stabiles was
wirtschaft und finanzen angeht und man
fragt sich natürlich kann er das
ernsthaft so sagen und ist es wahr was
er da sagt er
bezieht sich vor allem auf den rubel
kurs da muss man sagen dass dieser rubel
kurs tatsächlich höher ist als experten
erwartet hatten zu beginn des krieges
dass sich die währung tatsächlich
stabilisieren konnte aber natürlich
erwähnt denn nicht wie heftig einige
wirtschaftsbereiche in russland davon
betroffen sind allerdings das gehört zur
wahrheit eben dazu
profitiert er weiterhin von öl und
gaslieferungen insbesondere an europa
also da hat es ja nicht scharfe
sanktionen gegeben da gibt es hunderte
milliarden die er verdient und dann die
wirtschaft die er dort mit china und
anderen staaten aus der türkei die keine
sanktionen gegen russland verhängt haben
weiter durchführt und er sagt es ist
nicht die schuld russlands es sei im
misserfolge der weltwirtschaft und dann
noch ein wichtiger punkt er behauptet
die ukraine könnten ihre getreide
lieferung durchführen in diesen häfen
die ukrainische armee haben sich
familien russland habe nichts dagegen
auch das ist natürlich eine lüge denn
dort wo die häfen sind herrscht krieg
und da könnten russische truppen
jederzeit diese schiffe angreifen und
also wladimir putin zeigt sich hier in
einer tirade gegen den westen einer
tirade gegen diejenigen
die hier die ukraine unterstützen und
verteidigt erneut den krieg den er gegen
ein ganzes land angezettelt hat paul
abschließend die frage an dich wie
wirkte er sonst auf dich es gibt ja
immer wieder gerüchte er sei schwer
krank danach seien nicht aus oder
ich persönlich glaube diese gerüchte
ohnehin nicht solange es dafür keine
beweise gibt ich fand auch er sah anders
etwas
[Musik]
frischer als bei früheren auftritten aus
man muss ja auch eines dazu sagen die
lage für ihn zumindest militärisch hat
sich hier in der ukraine ein bisschen
verbessert in den vergangenen wochen
also diese schmach am beginn des krieges
wo er hier aus der aus kiew wo ich stehe
vertrieben wurde und die russischen
truppen sich zurückziehen mussten jetzt
hat man sich ja gruppiert im osten und
hat dort durchaus erfolge wenn man das
denn als erfolg bezeichnen kann wie er
militärisch er dort vorgeht wie brutal
er dort vorgeht und wie viele städte
russland dort kaputt bomb besten dank
paul ronzheimer live aus kiew zur rede
wladimir putins sankt peter